[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
kick some ass
get the girl and try to look dope how
you doing
three you wanted me back you could have
just asked me
the device that controls every military
satellite in the world
was fallen into the hands of four very
dangerous guys we need someone who can
move like them fight like them it's time
to be a patriot there are no more
Patriots just rebel and tyrants so which
are you
I'm xxx I'll introduce you to your
ground team all right it comes red
poster South I'm not gonna have clowns
watch my back who would you trust
[Music]
now that's a team I can work with
it's refreshing you know what you're
doing down there yeah that's what she
says wow these cases you all said the
real kind of trouble you have no idea
what you're up against
whatever it is they're looking for we're
gonna come up short
does this mean you're not making me
breakfast in the water we're willing to
die to keep the world safe how about you
I live for this I guess we're on the
same team now you ready to have some fun
I go along
maybe simple fast we kick some ass get
the girl and try to look dope why are
you doing
[Music]
dan it feels good to be back
[Music]
you